next question today David isn't it a
terrible idea for the 2020 Democratic
presidential candidate to be somebody
who lost their last election like bado
O'Rourke Richard Oh Jetta or Hillary
Clinton a very interesting question okay
we are seeing Richard o Jettas running
for president in 2020 there are
discussions about is Hillary going to
run again or not
she lost her last election bado
O'Rourke was defeated by Ted Cruz in
Texas slim margin particularly in such a
red state but he did lose so do we want
to put up someone whose most recent
election ended in defeat as a candidate
for president number one
Trump won okay nothing like this has
ever happened before
so saying it's just bad historically to
run people who are coming off of a loss
what do we know Trump won right I mean
anything is on the table everything is
on the table at this point now what is
not accurate is there are people who say
look Obama was a nobody when he became
president of the United States he had
been a senator for months before he
started running or however long it was
there is a difference though which is
that Barack Obama won his Senate
election as US senator from Illinois
that was his most recent electoral event
which he won and Richard o jeta lost in
West Virginia Hillary Clinton lost the
presidential in 2016
bado o'rourke lost in Texas so I think
that the answer is you've got to just
look at them one by one okay o jeddah
lost in West Virginia and he also stands
no chance I mean no offense to crystal
ball who's backing him and it's not an
attack on the guy but his story is he
supported Trump he voted for Trump but
then he had an awakening changed his
mind which is totally fine but this is
not the progressive that the left needs
Richard o jeddah with peace and love I
say it but the guy has no chance but
what do I know of course I mean I
thought Trump wasn't gonna win so take
everything I say with a grain of salt
beta or orc okay beta lost now the
difference with
IDO is that bado does have a charisma
that is significant compared to a Jetta
and if you ask me beta or Oh Jetta I say
bado for sure but it's still in the
realm of someone who lost their last
election what really matters is not
whether bado defeated Ted Cruz or lost
to Ted Cruz
it's conveyed o beat Trump at his own
game and I don't mean saying oh you made
fun of a disabled reporter I'll make fun
of a disabled newscaster I mean I'm not
I'm not saying that that's what he needs
to do in terms of playing Trump's game
but he needs to understand how to
respond to Trump's game because Trump is
good at it and he will crush someone
who's not prepared so should we have
this litmus test of Democrats shouldn't
run somebody who lost their last
election no you don't have to have won
your previous election to win
Trump proves that he never won any
election but if you're choosing someone
coming off of a loss you'd better damn
well be able to articulate why that is
somebody that is the right person for
Democrats despite having been handed a
loss in their last election send me your
thoughts should we care about this
should we care about the last results
that a potential candidate got or is it
not really important I want to hear from
you about it